the european union has handed down its
harshest measures yet to punish russia
for its aggression in ukraine after
weeks of wrangling the 27 member states
meeting in brussels have agreed to ban
most seaborne imports of russian oil by
the end of the year hungary opposed a
total embargo because it relies heavily
on russian supplies some eu leaders said
it was the best deal that could be
achieved
victor orban is celebrating his 59th
birthday at the eu summit here in
brussels
the hungarian prime minister however
already got his presence in the wee
hours when eu leaders agreed on an
embargo on russian oil
but with exemptions for hungary and
others
eu commission president ozula fonda line
still presented the water down deal as a
success
these sanctions are biting hard
and
are really um
destroying and that's the the goal uh
the basis the financial basis um of
putin leading this war and hitting hard
the russian economy
the eu plans to cut only russian oil
that's transported by sea
hungary slovakia and the czech republic
can continue to receive oil by pipeline
for now
according to eu officials in total 90 of
russian oil imports to the block will
stop by year's end
even those countries that would have
liked to see a stricture embargo say it
was most important to show unity i was
positively surprised because
when we went into the room
the signs were not that great but
everybody was very constructive those
who expect the eu to cut off russian gas
as a next step are likely to be
disappointed though
it is a lot easier to compensate for
russian oil we managed to solve
technical problems with victor orban gas
is a different story that's why a gas
embargo won't be part of a next
sanctions package
soaring energy prices all over the block
were also addressed as well as global
food shortages due to the war in ukraine
the responsibility for all dangers that
we are facing lies clearly with russia
and its president
that's why it's so important that we
reinforce our efforts to make sure syria
can be exported from ukraine
eu leaders will gather again in june on
this occasion ukraine's wish to join the
european union is likely to top the
agenda
dw's brussels correspondent max sander
joins me now max it was a long time
coming and it's only a partial ban
so is this a success for the eu
so um the eu commission president
fundamentally just heard speaking and
the eu council president xiao michel
after the end of day two of the summit
here called this as success
and indeed it was a long process it took
almost a month since this was initially
um initially brought up by the eu
commission this this oil this this oil
embargo on russia and it was a hard
decision um
that is likely to also impact the eu
economies to hurt them as well um and it
already we have already seen global
market prices for oil going up but that
being said and despite hungary uh not
having played along despite hungary
having an exception here in this embargo
we we're looking at a potential
reduction of 90 percent of oil that will
be
imported from russia uh to the eu this
is going to have an impact on the
russian economy nevertheless this is the
big chunk of the russian budget oil
means diesel it means petrol it means
other types of products and it's going
to have an impact a severe impact on
all these on these parts of the economy
and the large industry in russia
isla fonda line hinted she wants more
max but is there anything more we can
reasonably expect the eu to do at this
point beyond this in terms of imposing
energy sanctions on russia
well
gas would be the uh
the consequence this would be the the
next escalation of measures against
russia at the moment but as we know this
is a very complicated subject a lot of
countries in the eu are very dependent
on russian gas germany one of the most
dependent on it
large parts of the industry the chemical
industry for example to rely on russian
russian gas a lot jobs and livelihoods
are connected to it so phasing it out is
going to be very difficult for many
countries in the eu
countries are looking at alternatives
some liquefied natural gas for example
that can be that can be imported from
other countries such as the us or from
from qatar um but the infrastructure has
to be put in place um and then there are
also other countries in the eu for
example belgium that don't even have
significant imports of russian gas or
who said at the summit now that they're
very hesitant in going further with this
with this measure
worrying about impacts this could have
on the markets so gases um oil is
really can be seen as an achievement a
very difficult subject here but gas is
probably we're not going to see that
very soon briefly max what else came out
of this eu summit
so another important issue was food
security
ukraine is the bread basket of the world
and russia is essentially blocking
exports of grain um from from ukraine to
other parts some of the poorest
countries in africa and in the middle
east and the eu is now trying to
facilitate with the so-called green
lanes the exports that cannot take place
from from ports like odessa right now
because the russian navy is blocking it
to other countries in the eu um to uh
keep the supply chains going from their
respective ports in eu countries so this
is also another issue that was discussed
at this uh eu leaders summit maxander in
brussels thanks so much
for more on this uh mikhail krutiken is
an oil and gas expert based in oslo i
asked him earlier just how much this
partial oil embargo is going to hurt
russia's economy
the impact is going to be tremendous
because we
witness
oil production sites in siberia
slowing down
and the refineries in russia which
produce a lot of
refined products which
is exported to europe they also will
have to cut down their production to
decrease or some of them will close down
totally
and
all in all if we consider all the
impact on
ancillary industries that uh
help oil industry to prosper
i believe that
the revenues of the russian federal
budget this year
are going to lose about 25
25 is such a massive figure the eu has
been discussing an oil embargo for weeks
and the deadline uh for this to come
into effect is the end of the year has
russia got time to work around this to
eat into that 25 percent hit
i believe that the efforts were quite
sincere according to the declarations of
the russian government officials and the
president itself himself but uh well uh
everything pointed out to re-routing the
uh export flows of oil and refined
products to some other destinations
china and india but we know that the
transportation routes to china are
loaded to full capacity and just maybe
added a couple of tankers which would be
able to deliver oil from baltic ports to
china is not going to serve to be a
solution and india is not prepared to
accept more than maybe five to six
million dollar million tons a year
and when we look at uh europe europe uh
is consuming about 110 billion tons a
year
compared to the incremental deliveries
to
india hypothetical at this stage i don't
think india can be a solution as well
so you're saying in essence that these
other countries they cannot eat or they
cannot take any of this surplus product
it's worth backing over you think
there's nothing or not much russia can
do to mitigate against this ban they are
going to lose and lose big
yes i think it is pretty obvious that
russia is going to lose about 20 to 30
percent of its uh oil production this
year and next year if the situation
persists
the decrease will be about 50 percent of
russia russian oil production the
country is not going to be recognized as
the major energy power in the world
the flow on effect to this to the to the
average russian mikhail what impact will
these sanctions have then on the
ordinary russian people
i think first the uh
there will be quite a great wave of
people coming from oil rich areas to the
central russian cities as unemployed a
labor force and it will have a very
great impact
then i do not think that the russian
government is going to decrease the
price of gasoline and diesel oil at
petrol stations because the government
will need additional
income from retail sales to compensate
partially for the loss of revenues from
experts and so i do not believe that
there will be any improvement for
russian citizens in terms of
the energy
sector a significant day oil and gas
expert michael
critiquin in oslo many thanks for your
time
you